les 922 hectares du massif forestier de
l'étang salé ont de nouveau parcours
officiel l'orientation
plusieurs parcours structuré par des
cartes précises permettant de répondre à
une réelle demande scolaire et fédéral
le fondamental de la gestion d'une forêt
d'accueil du public comme comme celle de
l'étang salé c'est bien de prendre
conscience des besoins de la population
de leur envie peut-être de l'airé frais
d un petit peu parce qu'il ya des envies
qui sont pas très sympas on aime tous
chers de la moto faire du quad mais
c'est pas fait pour la forêt donc de
synthétiser un petit peu tout ça ne
partager ses objectifs avec la
connectivité au sens ce très noble du
terme collectivités représentant un
ensemble des usagers de la forêt est de
faire cohabiter tout ça et quand ça
marche quand ça fonctionne dans les plus
heureux des hommes
c'est celle ci donc on a cheminé comme
ceux ci on est allé sur la borne 3 qui
au niveau des constructions et nous
sommes sur la borne 7 c'est parce que là
je veux faire ce parcours
et oui les primaires est essentielle à
une primaire alors ça a été a été choisi
puisqu'il ya derrière tout autour donc
les gamins risque pas de se perdre
encore après la seule difficulté pour
les gamins pour ce plan c'est que faut
s'aider de la végétation alors ça peut
être un peu plus difficile pour la
saison d'après le représentant de mme
nss les gamins ont plus l'habitude de se
repérer avec des chemins
il utilise très peu la boussole en fait
ils orientent leurs plans et avec le
pussy ils orientent leurs plans et puis
se dirige au fur et à mesure pédestres
équestres et cyclistes cette nouvelle
offre sportive est financé à 60% par
l'europe et 40 % par le département pour
un coût total de 35 mille 555 euros
l'action du département c'est d'abord
l'entretien de la forêt un les
financements qui vont avec
la reforestation le reboisement
les emplois aidés qui sont mis à
disposition de leurs nf et serra et puis
l'entretien des différents parcours de
santé parcours vtt parcours équestre tôt
donc il ya vraiment de quoi satisfaire
une collectivité comme la nôtre pour
pouvoir faire en sorte que ce livre a
vraiment mis en valeur parce que c'est
le patrimoine du département avec près
d'une cinquantaine de bornes réparties
sur huit cartes le mouvement sportif
représenté par la fédération française
de course d'orientation ainsi que les
scolaires peuvent maintenant
s'approprier les lieux du matériel
pédagogique disponible sur le site du
conseil départemental